visez-vous d'aujourd'hui je suis super
content pas souvent jouer un fan km de
files d'attentes prédit ce qui est tout
simplement celle en haut des seins de
manches pour montrer aux mots ce qu'on
leur vaut qu'un bal c'est parti en gros
saint-fabien date précise mais où on se
déplace dans la maison et vous
graphiquement c'est un milliard de fois
mieux au mon gars c'est in c'est joe
assad watson ralph giles à opio
s'emballer ce texte un sas et de radio
pourquoi tout est flou bex abuser il a
déconné le gaz sur le fou alors attendez
regardez la porte s'ouvre tout seul
pourquoi la halle ok là là étaient
allumées on est bien on est chez nous
c'est quoi ce délire près des bruits
apparemment ils peuvent arriver de
n'importe où et nous il faut juste qu'on
survivent et il ya des zones dans
lesquelles on peut aller se réfugier
dans lesquelles il est bon ce ne
viennent pas je sais je sais pas je sais
pas ce que sega zone il ya des bruits au
c'est quoi c'est quoi ça mais qu'il y
avait aussi avancé avant s'il avance ou
laver son ombre déconner marche pas
alors ce que ces maisons plain-pied ou
ces maisons avec des étages aussi c'est
ça qu'on veut savoir actuellement il
convient reculait à l'aise que dans ces
tournois ont fait partie des maisons
éclairées l'autre partie complètement
cassés aux caméras what you're gonna do
[ __ ] i'm waiting for you you agree
bitschine tué l'un vers de la chanson de
james brown bb les excellents adore
l'humour ici et là les palois quand
est-ce que c'est la fin
les mieux le match je vous déteste tous
a les crocs bien en faire figurer de
merde vous baise à dont il est caché
mais qu il fait plus aucun bruit
il est caché
juste là et elle avec sa lampe torche
cherchait les toilettes vous dirai moi
la nuit je vois que tu as je vois rien
dans ce [ __ ] de jeu vous aurez éclairé
l'image au montage mais moi je vois que
dalle voyez plus là qu'est ce qu'il fait
il en réparation [ __ ] viens pas ici ok
j'ai un plan on va la tirer ici faire le
tour de ce petit pâté de maisons fin de
mur ensemble et à regarder où le cours a
mis face à face un mur en fait la bêtise
il me semble que ça paie des salariés ou
plus le lâcher patois dont il a besoin
pour si les superbes alors
terrifiant et terrifiant là le fait
qu'il court tu vois mrc reprocher tu ta
vie défiler devant ses yeux comme sa
maman qui passe est venu devant toi
quand elle sortait de la douche on était
petits on oublie ça ok on les retourne
au plus a commencé avec what a fact ont
tout préparé
ok en avant alors pas content je suis
persuadée du coup y'a pas de but du jeu
en fait à peut-être
attendez on va repérer sachs il y en a
deux autres au fond là il est terrifiant
salutaire ouattara a atteint donc on va
pas s'enfuir arrosait c'est pourquoi on
est vraiment fermé avec ce robot je suis
impressionné par la qualité du jeu pour
un bas de gamme quoi tout est
terrifiante même cette branche d'arbre
avec wadhaf d'anormal n'a pas la
profondeur il fait tellement de bruit
mec je vous jure brooke et julian walker
ne me fait tout bizarre aux usa cette
[ __ ] de lumière là tu sais pas si
c'est lui ou si c'est un vrai luxe trous
sont les lunettes de se mettre aux voix
tout frais au mexique et là bas je
l'entends je juge était mon jeu google
c'est bon pour ma feuille des couilles
labourage ces chewing gum en juger par
vous mentir excuse moi tu as pas vu les
nets bromés glasses you know something
like that est juste là où c'est moi
disputent un bruit on dirait une
photocopieuse il photocopies des
documents secrets c'est ça le conte
momo au genou en option la semoule à ce
moment là selon la ce pour l'aspect
alors environ vous claquez quétu
affaires bâtard sans dire un maigre
regarder alors cela me fait à chaque
fois j'ai reçu des pots de fleurs et un
bob regardez vous dirai pas de jambes et
à une tête
[ __ ] je deviens fou mais il va passer
l'arrière derrière les baies rien les
verriers à versailles est impressionnant
et très rapide attention c'est un cri de
femme
ok les gens c'est extrêmement court mais
extrêmement concentré à cause des
pellicules maintenant voilà ces nouveaux
écueils court après et lens comme ça des
pellicules
écoutez je pense qu'on a fait le tour de
la démo bah c'est sympa vous soyez une
maison il ya aucun objectif et
ajusteront beau cadeau qu'on a appris
qu'on passe trop près de lui cela
n'empêche que ça présage que du bon pour
la suite parce que le mec va incorporer
tous les persos et on pourra faire
vraiment les saoud faudra survivre cinq
nuits comme dans van natta devrez 10g
totalement apte power ça vous regarde et
on se retrouve dans une prochaine vidéo
portez vous bien de l'oni jouais pas si
vous avez le coeur qui fait comme ça
quand une voiture klaxons par exemple
aller à trop vite partout bien sûr tout
mon fils